quick rundown what do we got i'm fueled
up right now
oatmeal raisin for the win
24 tickarooskies
120 players cube fanatics
i am entered
let me just double check
i'm entered one minute war zone average
rating 17.77
times will be adjusted according to
players ratings
in order to balance things out let's
roll
i don't have a good feeling about it but
i'm gonna still try my best
if i'm gonna go down i'm going down
swinging
let's go
give me this little clock it's my best
friend now over here clock
you stay right here
out of the way let's go fire it up or if
you're not gonna fire it up give an
error and then give me points
give me air and give me points i might
be in first place
no you better not pair me up i just hope
they don't pair me up now give me the
error
give me the air and give me the points
show it right here give me a little
message
come on what a way to start here
okay just don't
don't pair me up give me the error
and then give me the points
in that order
or the other order the other order would
be good too
come on let's go what's
don't tell me there's some comcast
gambit here
don't tell me i have to get comcast
gambit guy on the horn here
oh
what a start wow look at this
look at this
come on
there's other people who have seven
games and look at what
did i get points for that
oh
what's going on here they're not pairing
me up
i got minus one what's happening look at
my score
i have negative one what's happening
do i have to refresh
i gotta refresh something's going wrong
refresh
oh man i already said it before it
started i said i have a bad feeling
about this let's go
let's go let's go
oh man
come on fired up fired up fired up
what's going on
let's go
i'm entered
they're not pairing me up
oh what's going on
do other people get to play i'm gonna be
jealous if a game pops up
i'm jealous they're playing and i'm not
oh
come on what's going on here
oh
man i waited for this
play bring it up bring it up bring it up
yes yes give me those points
give me the points okay i have to battle
from oh
i have to battle from being down i got
negative one no
no no no no no
come on h2 h2 is where it's at
can you feel it h2 h2 is happening soon
soon
free bishop
free bishop take the knight take the
knight he's still free take him
no charge
he's still free
okay he's got he's not free anymore but
wait i got this and i got the bishop
pac-man mode pac-man mode
pac-man
let's come here bishop wants to be on a
light square
light square bishop let's go bishop
i got another piece
kill the knight
light squares kill the queen next
e4
this square next actually i shouldn't
have
let's do this i want to get that pawn
can i get that pawn f3 mate soon
real soon
i want to cry i want to cry here
what is happening oh
castle before it's too late
they're being sneaky
oh what's up what's up with that
this is check
no i'm in check
wait where's the mate there's seven
mates and i missed all seven they want
to draw come on are you kidding me i
don't wanna draw yes oh they made their
mouse clicked
six what do i got one i got one point
oh man let's get that drop thing out of
there i don't have the clock either the
clock vanished on me i'm playing with
outside of the clock
oh
let's go let's go let's go i have to
fight back
come on be a champ here you can do it
chop this up give a check pin a piece
remove it
no matter what pre-move unless the king
goes to d7 it wouldn't do that would it
i should go here
let's back up the knight's gonna go
there i play here
oh the knight goes here i go here no i
got check no i don't
okay pins pins everywhere
pins pins everywhere
e7 the rook has to play here is it gonna
get beat up
uh oh resignation time
chop chop chop chop on dc d5 check
i'm on f6 be very scared check
flight square for my king
don't get mated
okay i'm going to take that and don't
don't you dare mouse slip no mo slips
just take the punt take that b-pawn
what's the matter with you
okay let's come over here
gobble him up
run b-pun
run
take this guy first
come on you should be resigning
this guy should be resigning he has 11
points in the tournament
he should be resigning let me grab that
i want to
make sure there's no
silliness
no stalemates either
another draw offer no i don't want to
draw back to tournament
17 16
i'm in 18th place five points
oh man
okay let's go here you can do it how
much time is left
h2
h2 is where it's at go right after h2
tko time
tko f3 is going to be played or is it is
it going to be played yeah f3 is played
but guess what i have this
or do i i do i might have it uh oh i
might sack
sakuruski okay i got this back i got the
bishop
ooh
tasty stuff tasty
let's break this open h2
oh but the knight has that square check
let's kick him around
i could get that rook but i don't want
it
oh
man this is dropping a piece
checks my bishop has a wonderful post
push here oh they're dropping everything
what are they doing
they're dropping pieces
i should take h2 sometime soon let's i
want to get an h3 my bishop on the light
squares
can i make that happen let's guard this
knight here hit the queen push my pawn
get my no no no no no no no no
no that would have dropped my rook if i
did that
i was going to move my knight to e5
let's not do that
okay rook do something
grab that pawn
we're going to have a bloodbath right
here a lot of a lot of pieces are going
to die on this square i could feel it
right here
boom boom
boom boom
a lot of pieces are dying right there
okay pigs
let's go with this
pigs pigs pigs pigs
cut them off one pig
looking for another pig
pigs
that's mate back to tournament eleven
come on you could do it you can do it or
can you 22 minutes and change there's a
lot of time left
don't run away
i'm gonna come back
i'm gonna come back
okay
f4 for the win
f4 for the win quick resigner i could
use some quick resigners that would be
wonderful that would be wonderful stuff
what is this night doing
oh
scary time no it's not
i have this guarded
black is the night going to go here
maybe it should knight d5 knight d5 be
very scared what's happening
they don't have this i have a block
they miss the queen
resignation time come on come on come on
come on
f7
bishop takes pawn i'm on the night the
knight is to run away scared knight d5
no
push that knight away
you have no oh i just dropped my knight
okay i'm on their
it's okay
it's all better it's gonna be okay
it's okay
it's gonna be all right let's go knight
weave a mate right here
be uh
be a mate weaver
h3 get out of my territory get this
light square bishop that night needs to
get out of my hair
get out of there knight
you have no business being in my
territory
no business
okay what do you do now
oh this is a one piece come on this is
resign time
resign time
let's do this
four karooskies
oh
let's go king
forks
what's happening give me that bishop
um
right here i want to do something
oh h7 okay i have h7
h7 let's take here discover checks
discover tricks
discover tricks be very scared chop
just want to burn their time anything
i don't want my clock to take back to
tournament 19
oh 42 39 is the top
i only have 19 speedy gonzo i have to be
flawless there are no i i can't i have
to win that's what i'm trying to say
here i have to win every game and i have
to do it fast
can i do it fast
okay can i get that dark for bishop
maybe
maybe yep okay stop oh i almost smell
slipped that one i'm gonna take
no
oh my knight on g4
g4 it can't castle so easily now
oh you bugger
you bugger you getting rid of my good
piece okay run away dark squares dark
squares everywhere b5 is where it's at
b5 that knight isn't doing anything
harmful is he
b-file
queen trait i get the b-pawn pile up on
the b-pawn that's the plan
hit the knight oh
they're constrained constrained pieces
right here queen is infiltrating
infiltrator
check
b-pawn is hit
it's dead my dark square bishop is a big
dummy
give me that pun
and
let's make sure that pawn doesn't go
anywhere my bishop needs some more work
here
oh no no no okay good
i thought there was take and then they'd
have a past pawn let's do this how much
time 30 okay
let's go bishop to e3 that pond isn't
going anywhere
not going anywhere give a check
let's back up and i'll capture like this
because i don't want the rook to make
use of the c file
i don't want that knight get into this
square no
no no no okay let's do this
and then
the knight's going to get there
oh he's a past pawn push him
i'm going to insert a check time burners
time burners
time burner pawn push how much time
check
that's not dropping stuff i thought it
was okay give me that night the rook is
dead or is it give a check
just come over here anything just move
i'm not getting quick wins i need quick
wins where are the quick wins back to
tournament 29 90 oh what a mountain oh
i'm dropping back 29
17 minutes and change oh give me your
queen oh this is going to be a tough one
knight c3
knight c3 quick resign they wouldn't do
that would they
f4 knight c knight f3 oh f7
be scared be very scared f7
f7
f7
finally knight here is good oh
defense
uh-oh uh-oh
i want to hang on my light square bishop
even though my knight would probably be
a
real annoying piece let's go take here
uh oh pin the knight knight d5 pin the
knight here we go knight d5 pinarooski's
pinarooski
grab this and then get some oh i'm on
the queen come on this is resign time
resign time
resign
you know this is resign time
oh queenie two get my rooks doing
everything
doing everything chop this up get to the
seventh pigs one pig another pig oh i'd
end up in a four let's take this square
away from the night oh come on this is
resign time oh kitchen sink variation
oh they're hitting me with the kitchen
sink
oh
run pun
let's go
check this is leading to mate
let's do it
they defend i hit it again check mate
and two
real close
pawn push i go queen here it's mate next
main two back determined 41
110 69 51 oh man 130. ah man 11 games
are you kidding me 11 games in 14
minutes
that is crazy that is uncalled for crazy
oh
man tempo on the queen
i think i have to look at second place
second place is where it's at
pawn push
tempo tempo caner
pin this knight and then attack the
knight
pin i'm dropping this pawn though
let's chop this up and then
let's go here i get this guy maybe at
the end of stuff
okay or maybe just a pawn push
what to do i want to just get in f6 you
might as well take this pawn chop him up
bishop first
the clock is ticking
clock ticker
38 39
oh forks
chop fork
on the queen at night
okay with time
let's go how much time is left out on my
little ticker
i need my little ticker
ah let's castle watch out for this
square oh i dropped my knight
get the queen it's okay come here hit
that c3 pawn
be careful though h7 better not fall for
any h7 tricks grab that pawn with the
check
queen right here to defend baby
oh i got to do this or wait i gotta
watch out for this maybe h6
let's get the queens off just to make
sure this game isn't gonna finish
no way it's gonna finish the bishop
might play there let's pre-move back
rank mate so run king run
run like a bandit here we go
pre moves pre-move
pre-move
okay back to tournament 55
150 man okay let's look at second place
can i get second place
after the start
oh man
that is a ridiculous score right there
ah
bishop c4 okay
i'm gonna have to run home with my queen
she's gonna have to run home
pretty much
pretty much run home
there is no night there my queen's
covering i'm on the night he's running
scared now and here we go
f5
f5 f-file open up is it going to open up
uh oh f7 big trouble for f7
pile up triple up pin a knight
kill the king
bishop g5 tko game over resignation what
do we have
come on chop oh i'm in a forward
it's okay i'm gonna add more fuel to
that that f6 knight
okay i'm actually just winning material
now let me do it like this first
sneaky
hit the queen
more forks in the air forks are
everywhere
more forks
crash through i'm up a full rook
move knight and then i get bishop e6
darn it
okay hit the knight and this is an ugly
pin can't get out of it
there's no getting out of it nope
that's not working
he's dead dead knight dead king come on
tip the king
time to tip back to tournament 71
i'm only 99 away you can do it pair me
up four times maybe
four times four or five times against
the top guy and i need to win them all
ah that's all
it's very realistic isn't it
that could definitely happen
four times come on my night i almost i
had flashbacks of the adobe flash gambit
right there oh
let's go here
oh this is scary time
scary time
check
i should have did that previously
that night's unprotected i should have
beat him up while i had the chance go
back here
oh i'm getting a lot of material
oh i'm netting a lot of material
oh there goes the knight
i got the rook next
inbetweener bishop here if the rook
moves the queen's dead the queen's dead
dead queen
dead queen
resignation come on
resign
is there a way to catch that guy
there's no way is there
99 points out
come on clock burner
i've done that before
when i cramped up who was here for that
i wanted to move my king to h1 but i had
a cramp
that's right at the end of a tournament
ah let's go here
a clock burner clock burner
let's go tick tick tick tick tick five
minutes and change
oh
all righty
back to tournament 89
oh 180 14 out of 14. how do you have 14
games in that's pretty crazy
okay gambit land
bishop c4
knight g5
do i have it
come on i got material
resign time that would be great
that would be wonderful
yes back to tournament that was great
109
that was great okay come on let's go i
got 10 games in
109 105 is on my heels nap strong player
strong player bononi
okay do i get tempos tempos tempos
tempos
i got the tempos
oh man if you're new to chess and you're
hearing that you're probably scratching
your head what in the world are what is
he talking about engaged fishing pole
there's another one
there's another one to make you go crazy
fishing pole
ah i'm on the rookie i'm on that rookie
i want it get your knight to g5
let's do it
uh oh be very scared
be very scared
be very scared
mate threat
i'm gonna i'm just gonna do this even if
it's wrong
it's very scary
very very scary territory right here
okay
break this open
there should be a capture here
ah
sneaky move i didn't see that that's
okay the queen is tied down to the
defense now break this open mate in two
take the pond you know you want to take
it there's pawn push though
uh oh uh oh i'm on the rook and mate
looking me
uh oh
take this rook first
and then
take this pawn and then take the bishop
can i take that bishop next no i can't
do that my rook wants to play he's not
doing anything oh my queen is close to
dead no she's not
close call right there grab the knight
checks
mate soon real soon
my rook is defending my bishop
they're gonna see that
they didn't see it
what am i doing
oh there's rook check i should have done
that
rook check
and then my other rook okay back to
chairman they forfeit a time
okay
all right come on is that happening no
it's not
not catching first
no way
that is a ridiculous lead
knight f3
okay so
just want to maybe secure what can i
secure okay this is light square damage
light square issues pawn structure
damage here
um
push just a single square i guess bishop
g5 okay i got material here
got that rookie
and now get my knight out of the way
oh is he really out of the way he is
he could have been taken as well he's
also trapped he's also a trapped knight
so let's do this in the meantime get
this pawn rolling and my knight central
and maybe get this file working take
that pawn it's free
but i get the b file
in between her knight takes i take here
i'm on the queen in between her and it's
with check there is no night here on my
queen
open it up
give a check
hit the rook
oh come on that's a big blunder
resign time
no resign time
bishop check
no
the king's gonna flee let's stop that
where is he fleeing to
where is that king fleeing to
over here making one uh-oh
look right here
right here take the bishop and then go
hear me
that's the plan i could take the bishop
if there's a check also this is a pin
ah come on
mate one back to tournament 149 220 149
six minutes and change i need quick
resigners
there's 150 players in the tournament
right now
can i come back from this i'd need help
i would need help
quick resigners is this guy going to
resign no
false alarm
no fast resigner on this one
all right i um
i can't really go knight g4 route nope
okay maybe i can get e5 in i could hit
the queen at any any second
let's do this and um my light square
bishop wants to play
ah so let's go actually let's get their
light square bishop let's make sure that
that light square bishop is dead and
this development with tempo more tempo
of pond blocks
actually let me chase that knight away
and then hit the queen next maybe
actually they're gonna hit my bishop
man
um
let me do this it's a little scary pawn
push is probably good
got that open file
no that knight's going to kill me
ah why'd i do this i should take that
pawn okay i got it now
and then i'm going to plant
oh i'm on the queen
i missed that
check and then just make sure their dark
square bishop is out of the game here
watch this guy and open the position up
the knight was ready to go there i
should probably just capture the night
it's too much of a pain the tricky night
you gotta go you definitely have to go i
cannot tolerate you
check
connect
and then push my pun
he's the furthest one advanced let's get
him going
capture and then roof block
give a check
what are we going to have
pawn push
take i got this guy
you're next pun keep going keep going
keep going not so fast
hang on they're being sneaky there
no stalemates
check
check
that mate
this is me
okay back to tournament 169.
oh let me just make sure i get second
place
oh right at my heels
169 168 vexium okay let's be realistic
here
second place i'm gonna count that as uh
victory yes back to tournament 189.
oh
189. here we go rick rick john 47
another quick resigner
oh no anything but this
anything but a non-mover
oh
man ah let's go clock tickers
man
i'm really anxious here i'm really
anxious to see this top guy how he has
18 games in
okay we're live here okay back to
tournament 199.
here we go 261.99 i think i'm having
second place again vexium
is this another quick resign
double the point to resign
yes wait hang on i'm sneaking up 219.
let's go
if this keeps happening i'll get there
i need like seven wins in a row and they
all have to be quick resigners pawn
center
okay this knight is going to get pushed
around or is he yes he is
here we go
launch that h-pawn
h-pawn i got to support this guy push
the pawn actually now everything is
sealed
those knights are out of the ball game i
want to hang on to my dark square bishop
so if the knight centralizes itself i
take and then i play h4
breaking this open my queen could come
out to g5 right away
real soon or even h4
let's chop this
i'm on that pawn my naked play here the
rook is hit queen side castle of the
double on the h file
coming up very soon chop there's check
after it and then a rook to h2
check rook right here actually it's a
mate
this is better mate in two
cool mate back to tournament 239 300.
oh man two and change
okay this is probably gonna be the last
game this guy doesn't resign yes he does
249 hang on 300 249. i'm getting some
help i'm sneaking in gm night
let's go
what are we gonna have here
oh player
it's not a non-mover or it's not a quick
resigner
it's a player here this is a player
okay let's go with i'm not even
threatening to take that bishop did you
know that
hold on push
oh i could take it with my knight though
chase i have a threat hit here and then
i take the bishop
be very scared okay i win material my
rook is defended
i'm gonna
do what next i'm on the queen
uh-oh
okay let's go bishop you're doing
nothing i'm on the queen i'm on the
bishop hit the knight grab a pawn take
this knight first
get that knight out of there queen a5
queenside castle pawn push here get that
knight out of there
give a
check queenside castle i really don't
want to do that let's come over here how
much time is left i don't have my little
clock anymore
clock is long gone takes okay i have
this rook
right here
on the rook grab that pond there's no
need to castle i don't think
f2 next
i'm going to take that i have that
covered
oh run i have this covered the queen is
there sneaky
be very sneaky oh let me just make sure
that that is out of there so i guess i
am castled now
looks like a castle but i really didn't
did i
it's this pigs looking for pigs pigs
pigs pigs
two pigs looking for
another check
what's going on can i just get this win
right here is this close to
win
chase that king out flush the king out
give another check
another one just for fun
what do we got four foot on time back to
tournament 16 seconds okay
ah
thug
quick resign
there's no that's it that's the ball
game there's no that's the tournament
oh that's it second place
man
oh man
what a start to that tournament 3 30 for
first
good games all
330 269 195
176.
i was in confetti land at least i got
the confetti
uh